the second popular choice by the black
Camp is to play Bishop to F5 and against
this I am going to propose a new move
which is not even in the top white
choices and that is Knight to H4
attacking this bishop
immediately well black has few options
and amongst them Bishop to G6 is by far
the most popular choice however
let's check out other moves
E6 bad choice as we can take on F5 and
after e takes F5 white should be
delighted because black get a set of
double pawn something in order to
achieve white has to give up the bishop
pair but here it comes a free of
cost so in a long run this position
always serves better for the world
what about Bishop to D7 here well this
time around we can simply continue with
D4 and after E6 and Knight to F3 we
enter into the French Advanced
variation and as I have highlighted over
here white has a very simple plan with
the space in the center and the big
question is if black really want to play
French then why he choose the
caran so that means Bishop to G6 more or
less you can expect from most of your
games and after this we immediately take
the bishop which at first s side looks
like opening up the black Rook but the
matter of fact
is after White's next reply that is
EES
well guess
what yep we sets up yet another tricky
platform for the
black first thing first the idea is very
simple we want to take on F7 and give
black some horrible Pawn structure on
the king side and accordingly black has
tried three
choices number one if he continue with
the most popular choice F captures
E6
I'm afraid this is very bad as this is
playing right into the White's
hand white has a lethal move here namely
Queen to G4 which shatters All Black's
hope we have a double attack and in the
database there are some games continue
with Knight to F6 which is a big time
inaccuracy as after Queen takes G6 and
King to D7 black king is all around the
place
whereupon after D4 if you look at the
results they are tremendous for the
white so nope that's not the right
idea black should defend both of this
Pawn with King to
F7 and white would love to play here
Bishop to D3 except that Rook to F6
spoiling the party so that gives you
hint for the White's next move yep D4
stopping Rook to F6 and now indeed we
are threatening Bishop to
D3 well my recent game against
2300 gives you a very good idea how
dangerous this position is for the
black my opponent continue with Knight
to F6 attacking my
queen and since white still has a threat
of Bishop to D3 He played Queen to
D6 trying to ex CH the
queen well this looked good at First
Sight except one problem that after
Bishop to
F4 black get a completely disgusting
position the threat is very simple in
the next move we want to play Bishop to
D3 and if you think that this queen to
B4 check solves all black issues well
thinkwise as after Knight to D2
there are three choices for the black
all miserably
fails first queen captures B2 is a big
time blunder here guys as white has this
simple sequence Rook to B1 Queen to D4
and now sting in the tail Bishop takes
B8 which wins the peace and in fact
white Onslaught on the black king remain
as it is
so nope Queen captures B2 is not
possible here what about if I save my
knight well then you fall for Bishop to
D3 and there is no way now black can
save this Pawn so that is also not a
good
choice and last but not least black has
tried here Knight to H5 but
unfortunately this fails due to this
wonderful move Queen 12
three so now white has a threat of
Bishop to D6 nabbing The Black
Queen so black king has to move out of
it but then we have this simple sequence
Bishop captures G8 Rook captures G8
Queen to E3 and after Queen to
D6 time and time again pay attention to
this patn as when white managed to put
the Knight on F3 it has a deadly
consequences as this Knight can goes to
either of these juicy squares where the
fact remain on the table is this dark
Square Bishop is a complete dead wood in
the black
cam the second move I want to consider
is
F6 and against this more or less same
story we play Queen to G4 attacking on
G6 black has to play G5 and now very
nice move by wide
F4 well in one of my bullet game my
opponent continue with Knight to H6
where Queen to H5 finished the game on
the
spot so those sort of blunder can happen
in quick
games there are two popular choices here
and amongst them the first one Rook to
H4 looks good but in fact it's a mistake
as after Queen to F5 we are threatening
a Checkmate and after the base sequence
that is Queen to D6 giving the space to
the black king we deliver this check and
when the king move we have this nasty
reply Queen to
F7 where Queen is saying Hell hello to
this bishop and Knight and there is
nobody to save this poor
fellows so that sort of disaster happen
when black plays the move Rook to
H4 probably the most accurate response
here is Queen to
D6 giving up the pawn but white will be
more than happy as after Pawn takes G5
Pawn takes G5 we can simply respond with
D4 where we cover this important check
and our next Target is Munch this G5
Pawn with a devastating
effect in fact there is a feed game
between two 2200 plus rated players
where black choose the moon night to
F6 and his idea is to move the queen
away from the A6 Pawn which wisely
enough white avoid
it and after this I think black is in a
huge trouble number one if you play
Knight to A6 white can simply chop it
off number two we have a threat of Queen
to G6 and we can also take on G5 and
considering all this aspect black find
nothing better than going for the
counter play with Rook captures H2 but
what he missed is this very nice
tactic can you see
it congratulations if you find the move
Bishop to
F4 creating a disconnection between
Queen and rook and it is so effective
that even after Queen to B4
check we don't need to play Bishop to D2
but rather very strong move Knight to D2
which at first side looks impossible
right because now black can take your
rook and on top of everything black has
some severe threats going
on so what is white up
to fasten up your seat Bel guys as you
are going to witness one of the most
surprising move in this line and that is
Bishop to
C7 wow simply
wow that looks very special right the
idea is now we have shut down all the
doors for the black king white has a
simple thread Queen to G6 a
Checkmate but hang on you might say Rook
to at6 prevent every single of it right
well guess what nope as after Bishop to
D3 indeed white is delivering the
Checkmate and a big thanks to this
wonderful dark Square Bishop as because
of his presence this is only possible
from this
position last but not least what to do
against the move
F5 okay since we don't have Queen to G4
we should continue with
D4 and it doesn't matter however black
plays so Knight to F6 and queen to D6
are some of the most popular
choices but against each of them our
response will be very
consistent so for example if your
opponent continue with Knight to F6 then
we can respond with
G3 and the same story goes if he played
the move Queen to
D6 which is the accurate
choice we need to protect our Pawn so
Queen to E2 and after Knight to F6 do
you remember yep
this small little cute move G3 which can
create wonders as we have a threat of
Bishop to F4 and kicking the queen out
of that important
Pawn in fact now we are going to follow
a Blitz game of a 2600 plus rated player
where black continue with some obvious
choices Knight to A6 planning to Castle
on the quein
side white reveal his nasty Trump Bishop
to
F4 and please note that if black
continue with Queen to d8 then we have a
very simple idea that is Knight to D2
Knight to F3 and then this Knight Will
land on either of this juicy
Square where with the castle on quinide
this position is very Superior for the
wide so in the game and in fact as for
the database all the games continue with
Queen to B4 check which turn out as a
big mistake as after C3 attacking the
queen queen to
B6 white plays a very nice move Knight
to
D2 whereupon in a long run black is
going to feel the heat because of white
tremendous squeeze on the black king
Su so as happened in many games black
get had fed up with the white
attack and he tried to create his own
counter with Queen captures B2 but
exactly here white reveal his nasty
attacking scheme starting with Rook to
B1 Queen captures C3 Rook captures B7
attacking the Knight so Black Knight has
to come forward and although Knight to
C2 looks very
scary white indeed played the best reply
Queen to E5 and after this what else
black get a completely losing
position well he tried his best with
Knight check and after King to D1 he
take on D4 dreaming of checkmating white
king but white finished the black
elegantly from here with this nice Queen
sacrifice where the matter of fact is it
is blacking who get busted at the
opening
stage